if you ever saw a wooden surfboard it
was probably hanging in somebody's house
or underneath the deck but kind of in
the last 10 or 15 years Wood has made a
big comeback they surf wonderfully
that's beautiful it feels great to be on
I always had a love for wood and kind of
passionate about things that went in the
water I've kind of been around wooden
boats most of my life there's just so
much character the way they're built the
stories that come with a lot of that has
translated over to why we build
surfboards the way we do well we first
started thinking about building
surfboards Wood was the natural material
we chose they have a very high strength
to weight ratio wooden surfboards have
the longest history of use in the surf
world than any other material people
have been surfing wooden surfboards for
since kind of the first documented
history of people riding waves board
starts in CAD where we take a 3d model
break down the shape and kind of create
frames and templates and all the inner
parts of the board that we get cut
[Music]
we take those frames and we just pop
them out assemble the frame into kind of
a skeleton we go out to our lumber shed
pick a bunch of cedar and bring them
into our milk shop put glue on the edges
clamp it all together to a panel
everything's booked match you have
symmetry and the colors and texture of
the wood cutting your outline take our
assembled frame gently put it down right
on top of the plane once that foundation
is started you're basically building up
the three-dimensional shape the outside
part of the board using lots of strips
that kind of interlock and fit together
every piece of wood is gonna be
different and it's all going to react
differently there are frustrations with
it but I think that's one of the things
that keep the challenging you learn to
read the kind of what the grain lines
are doing and what the color of the wood
is telling you once those rails are
cleaned up we put our top planks on it's
a little bit like putting a lid on a box
it's like this is it whatever it's
inside that board is staying inside that
by tensioning some rope you can clamp
the two together it's like a time
capsule what makes our board unique are
they are built right here in York
they're built using material that grows
right here in the state of Maine they're
built 100% by hand by local craftspeople
and surfers there's a lot of time that
goes into these boards between 40 and 60
hours to finish we wanted to build
surfboards that were as hollow as they
could be but still be strong enough to
work well too late and they don't surf
well but too heavy and they don't surf
well so there's a balance point there
and that's where we try to be taking the
board off the rocker table once the top
has gone on that is by far one of my top
favorites parts it's just you and a
shaping stand a board and a hand plane
everything else is out of your view it's
simple it's pleasurable it's quiet you
could be with your thoughts and you can
just kind of be present there's
something about taking a nice sharp edge
tool to a beautiful piece of wood and
feeling the curls coming off and knowing
that every pass that you're making
you're kind of getting it closer and
closer to what you have in mind once
we've shaped it down and the board's
looking like it's supposed to look like
transferred to go into the glass and 1/4
ounce fiberglass laying it over the
board draping it over the edges cutting
it applying epoxy and on the board
once both sides are Lam coated it's time
to put in the hardware drill and router
and install the feed box and on the
other side we drill and put in the lease
plug and event there's a lot of error
just naturally inside the board and that
air wants to expand and contract with
temperature changes and that vent has a
little piece of gore-tex fabric in it
and it allows air to kind of breathe
both ways but it doesn't want water once
all that Hardware is put in goes back
into the glassing room we brush a nice
beautiful thick coat of epoxy over the
whole surface and that we call a gloss
coat that's supposed to look beautiful
and glossy and shiny and flawless you
get to see that board come to life
whatever the colors in the wood they
really come out it just makes it look
like candy you just want to touch it and
run your hands down it and it's just
kind of icing on the cake
once everything is hard we put it into
what we call the oven get that epoxy to
cure really kind of bake it and just get
it to harden put in the fin screw in the
vent then ship it out we just love the
idea of building something that's
sustainable and long-lasting and made by
hand
so it gives you a deeper connection to
the product over something you might buy
on a shelf
[Music]
when a customer gets the board they feel
it they a hundred percent feel the
amount of work and the amount of passion
that went into the board so I'm not
really looking at hours and efficiency
and looking at like doing it right and
enjoying it as we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
you